today's one minute monday is donate your
time i believe that as an entrepreneur
you have a responsibility to help the
people in the community and give back
and share your wisdom to make them
better so i was recently asked by
enactus to judge a student entrepreneur
competition for them the only problem
was it was on a monday i hate saying yes
to things on a monday i almost never do
it monday is my get stuff done for the
weekday it's where i get everything i
need done for the week so i can go enjoy
and have fun on the rest of the week but
it was an important cause and it was
helping entrepreneurs so i said yes it
took me basically the whole day there
listening to four entrepreneurs pitch
their ideas and giving them feedback to
help them pick a winner we finished
around four o'clock and i rushed to my
car to get back so i could start doing
work but on the car ride back all i
could think about was those four student
entrepreneurs and how their
presentations could have been better i
wish i had the opportunity to talk with
them and meet with them and give them
feedback on how they could improve for
the next time they go out and do it so
when i got back instead of going into
the work that i had missed for the
entire day i sat down and made four
videos for each of the entrepreneurs
giving them feedback i spent the next 40
minutes making individual videos for
them giving them personalized advice for
how they could improve i emailed them
the videos later that day and they were
all blown away with the advice and
feedback and i could tell that it really
made a difference for them so even
though i had work piling up and piling
up and piling up i spent the day to go
help them and then came back and made
those videos for them because it was the
right thing to do you have an obligation
and a duty to help others as well so
take some time this week to mentor
somebody and see the positive impact you
can have on their lives and believe
self-improvement books are like fitness
books they never work on their own what
you need is a trainer that's evan get
the newsletter
you